harry and megan are married they're
gonna have a baby on page 231
you talk about charles asking camilla
what he thinks the complexion right of
the baby will be right right now what's
interesting about this context is
everything and that's the important part
here harry and megan during the oprah
winfrey interview right said that they
had learned that a royal had made kind
of a racially charged comment about skin
tone and there was now some concern and
apprehension within palace circles about
what that would mean for the for the
look of the monarchy well the first
thing harry and megan did was to make
sure that people knew it wasn't the
queen or prince philip who made a lot of
questionable statements they were not
the guilty parties but the queen said
there were uh you know varying
recollections as to who might have made
some comment and that they would deal
with that problem privately i was able
to trace back through a comment that was
made by charles to camilla over
breakfast the day their engagement was
announced look i'm a grandfather i can
tell you grandparents of course
speculate on what their kids are going
to look like you know eye color hair
color you know skin color whatever yeah
but that's this is different asking what
the complexion of the child will be when
harry is marrying a woman who's biracial
and it's the she's biracial and he's the
world's most famous redhead it was
innocent benign there was nothing
negative got to remember at this point
charles is really fond of megan yes and
he's becoming very friendly with megan's
mom doria ragland you know but it was
taken it was kind of perverted and
warped and and weaponized by the uh men
in gray to be used uh to kind of stir up
trouble okay i have to drill down on
this just a little bit here christopher
because i know you're saying it was an
innocent remark by him by him right even
if it was innocent it does not mean that
it wasn't racial right and that like if
as a woman of color if i marry a white
man and my soon-to-be father-in-law is
sitting having breakfast with my
soon-to-be mother-in-law and he says i
wonder what complexion the baby's going
to be i'm still going to feel some kind
of way about that there's no question
that that megan and harry are right to
be yeah i find that kind of shocking and
awkward but i don't think it was
convenal and racist in the way that was
then made out to be was it blown out of
proportion that's what what charles felt
yeah obviously but you know there's no
question that racism exists in the
aristocracy in england that exists
throughout the nation uh the difference
between americans and and brits is that
we talk about it
they never talk about it it's hard to
imagine that just that statement can be
perverted into something else because
just that statement on its face right is
perverse but charles has now come out
palace has come out and said that's not
true right that's fiction right this did
not happen well i've been covering the
the royal family for 50 years which is
horrifying but anyway
but i haven't i wrote about the royal
family for time magazine i handled all
of people's royal coverage in the 70s
and 80s i've written six books about the
family i can tell you that the first
thing they do is deny that they are the
emperors of denial that is true and uh
so i have rock solid sources that verify
this is what happened you stand by i
said absolutely stand by everything in
the book
you